I
that's the hit song closure by superstar
little Nozick's the orders quickly rose
to fame with Old Town Road you know it
it broke the record for billboards
longest-running number one song of all
time Wow
that happen even is nineteen the rapper
whose real name is Montero Lamar Hill
revealed closure was his way of coming
out as gay he told us the journey to
making that announcement was not easy
did you know as a little boy did you
were gay did you think that is a
youngster while people are telling you
it's not a good thing were you thinking
yeah but yeah I am definitely
I knew especially like around my teenage
like years you know I was just like you
know pray and pray and pray and what
were you praying for that it was like a
phase yeah go away I'm good with it but
I'm not gonna tell anybody yeah yeah I
mean cuz me being in this position like
it's easy for me but like some little
boy 10 miles from here not gonna be good
for him mm-hmm but don't you think you
coming out that could probably help
others who were struggling the way you
were struggling with it I think he's
gonna always help you know it's gonna
you still have a long way to go because
it's not like everybody is like messing
with me now cuz of course somebody was
like listening to me in school right now
it's like you gay cause you listening to
him so it's like it's still a lot to be
done of course but I do believe is
helping yeah I mean imagine here is 19
he's now 20 he's turned 20 since we've
done that interview but he said he
struggled with it and then he saw signs
that he should come out that he should
come out and tell his own truth he has
no regrets that he's coming and it
certainly hasn't hurt his career he was
worried about that
that certainly has not been the case
always so sad when you hear people say
you know oh I knew but I wish you were
yeah
I thought it was a phase this is not a
phase he is really really an awesome
awesome young person who really is just
getting started in this business